this is a production of cornell
university
so i hope you've had a chance to read
some of these but we'll get back to it
later
i'm going to make the argument today
that plant breeding targets
need to pretty much fundamentally change
because we've accomplished
a lot of the key goals over the last
century
to talk about what we've accomplished
and what we
perhaps need to change too
and so before i get into it i want to
talk about how does change happen
we start off something we're familiar
with the shift to hybrids um
it was based on a technology
breakthrough uh
that essentially gave a 20 increase in
yields
and when it started to hit iowa as a
commercial product
it essentially swept it in about six
years
and of course these shifts aren't just
with corn and agriculture
the u.s car came in and essentially in a
10-year period
replaced the horse destroyed numerous
prior markets that had
listed lasted for millennia and it
essentially created
much of the 20th century economy
the shift that we remember much more
closely of course is the smartphone
shift again
in the the smartphone took over the
entire
market in about nine years destroyed all
sorts of other technologies that
had been out there separate industries
but also created lots of other
new technology areas social waves
and even enable remote work so how has
change impacted breeding
well i define breeding as the design and
selection of organisms for human
purposes
so while the technology and knowledge
and scientific discovery around
hybrid vigor really started around 1908
and but by the time it hits the market
in the 1930s
then you see this first big increase in
yield
and then through iteration and breeding
over the last 80 years we've had it
resulted in this eight-fold increase in
meigs yield
half from coming in from genetics and
half coming from agronomy
and that type of success has
dramatically
changed the shape of the united states
ag productivity gains have essentially
allowed time for modern life
the vast majority of americans no longer
live in rural environments
and only a small proportion of the us
now
is involved in farming that breeding
success has also resulted
in some ecological gains for example by
getting those higher yields the northern
part of the us now has 16
more forested land than did in 1900
despite having much larger populations
and of course internationally what's
happened with britain
is that now the vast majority of the
globe's population
has enough calories and protein a lot of
that comes from the efforts of people
like norman borlaug and the green
revolution to deliver
these changes in breeding and agronomy
globally
those were tremendous successes in the
last century but
what are this century's challenges i
think our first challenge
is really improving global diets while
the prior century
reduced the problem with insufficient
calories and protein we still have the
vast majority of the globe's population
with imbalanced diets
either poor nutrition or too many empty
calories
i think the vision we should be going
towards
is one where we've essentially
eliminated everybody with insufficient
calories for protein
by providing access to alternative
proteins
and really adapting those productive row
crops across the globe
and then the second area is we really
need to tackle these imbalanced diets
and they're talking
about making it accessible to get to
quality fruits and vegetables and all
sorts of microbial foods
if we can tackle those two issues then
most of the planet will have a healthy
diet
at the end of the century our other
giant challenge of course is dealing
with climate change
that means dealing with increased
temperatures it means
dealing with pests and diseases that are
destroying our crops
as they move into new environments
it means dealing with extreme weather
events
more floods more droughts and damaging
wind events
but of course plant breeding can also
play a key role in ameliorating these
issues of course we need to come up with
better abatement technologies in the
production
of energy but we also can
play as i'll discuss a really key role
in potentially doing carbon removal
so i think plant breeding should really
be focused in on
creating healthy diets a circular
agriculture
and sequestering carbon and so why
aren't we focused on these
i think it's because a couple other
demands have really been focusing our
attention
these other areas haven't been the big
focus
because plant breeding has been in the
middle of supporting
a massive seven-fold increase in protein
demand
that's essentially stretching over 90
years
to meet this protein demand essentially
half of all habitable land on the globe
is being used by agriculture
three quarters of that ag land is for
livestock and the rest of it's for crops
so essentially we're pretty much already
maxed out for use of
land
and the u.s really isn't any different
from the rest of the world
this is a graphic made by bloomberg and
you can see that livestock
really dominate land use across the u.s
and the proportion
of area we use for food we directly is
very modest
even if you look at our cropland
essentially
our form largest production systems
wheat hay soybean and corn are really
all about calories and protein
and a lot of them are all about really
supporting
these protein production systems
and so if you ask what is the food
system's biggest challenge
it's figuring out how to get nitrogen
and protein
into people's diets efficiently and
dealing with these increases in
population
and still many people around the globe
don't have enough
the issue is that humans already
dominate the nitrogen cycle
we control about fifty percent of the
nitrogen flux per year
in contrast we only control about six
percent of the carbon flux per year
and yet we still have a massive problem
with climate change
it's estimated that essentially half the
people on the planet are
here directly because of the invention
of the hoverbox nitrogen fixation
reaction
so we are in an area with nitrogen where
we're already with our current
production approaches essentially maxed
out
so why is the system so complex
uh why are we using so much well
a lot of it is because we have a very
complex system
for how nitrogen gets to you starts out
with us
essentially in the united states case
drilling a hole in the ground
extracting uh natural gas from that
creating hydrogen from that
plugging that into the harbor bosch
reaction
creating fertilizer injecting it into
the field
we hope our plants take up some of it
they're used to synthesize amino acids
which is then used for photosynthesis
it's then remobilized into the seed and
we harvest it
and then we give it to our livestock we
grow those animals we slaughter the
animals
and we eat the animals and so in each
one of these steps
scientists and engineers and
and business people have farmers have
worked very hard to optimize them
but of course the problem is the total
number of steps here
it isn't just that harbor bosch
has issues it's that essentially
biological we got into the situation
because biological nitrogen
fixation is land inefficient so if you
compare
mage yields versus soybean yields
they're grown by the same farmers
on the same fields using the same
equipment and essentially maize yields
about three times as much per
acre as soybeans do and a lot of that
has to do with the amount of energy
soybeans used to fix nitrogen globally
we face a similar type of situation
for example in sub-saharan africa where
we're expecting to have the largest
population growth in the rest of the
century
essentially in order to
get sub-saharan africa to be
self-sufficient by 2050
we either need to vastly increase the
amount of land under agriculture
or vastly increase the amount of
nitrogen
and that is the fundamental trade-off
that
needs to go on in order to make some of
these areas across the globe
self-sustaining and i want to highlight
that nitrogen although it's critically
important
it's also one of the major inputs
and major energy costs and major farmer
costs
for their crops so although maize is a
very efficient crop more than 10 to 1
energy and
energy out over half of the energy input
is coming from the
nitrogen fertilizer
and if you look at the greenhouse gas
emissions for a crop like maize
over 80 percent of its greenhouse gas
emissions are coming from
nitrogen so we've talked about the
weaknesses of plants but of course
animals are actually the least efficient
portion of the process
with beef being the most inefficient at
only about three percent of
efficiency well eggs are actually quite
good
at 31 efficiency but overall
animals are very inefficient at
converting
input protein to human-consumed protein
how does nitrogen get to you we're
essentially using about one percent of
the
globe's energy to produce fertilizer
we lose about 50 percent of the nitrogen
when we try to get into the plants
and then we can essentially lose
anywhere from nearly 70 percent to 97
of that measuring amino acids as we
go through animal production so
i want to end here with essentially that
thought experiment how close could one
get to maximum efficiency what would
that look like
well a single person needs about 57
grams of protein per day
and we break that down into those amino
acids that make it up
we assume we get the nitrogen through
some
energy process such as plasma generation
of fixed nitrogen we're then going to
get the carbon from glucose
and that could come from something like
maize that works out to be
about half an year per day and if we
scale that across the globe
essentially you could feed 7.6 billion
people
on about 21 million hectares of land
that's about the area of kansas and if
you look globally
essentially 1.5 percent of
global arable land could fix all the
carbon needed for the global protein
demand
so on a straight chemical processing
point of view
it doesn't actually take that much land
to produce
all of the protein necessary to support
the planet
so from a straight chemistry point of
view yeah it looks like it could be
fairly straightforward to support the
planet
but does any of this make economic sense
this is the type of question that
rethink x
was asking and they published a report
on this last year
and i would highly recommend that
everybody take a look at that
but their central premise is that
precision fermentation
essentially the production of high
quality proteins
this basic biology has really been
figured out
and engineering has been figured out
over the last five or ten years
and it gets continuing to roll out and
so
in the next four years they expect those
precision high quality proteins to only
cost about ten dollars per kilogram by
2024 and down to as low as one dollar
per kilogram
by 2035 and because of that they
expect nearly a 70 reduction in cows
because essentially those production
numbers are so low
that these high quality proteins will
out compete animal protein in the market
they've modeled how precision protein
costs have developed
over time starting with things like
insulin and then
industrial enzymes for cleaning and now
industrial enzymes for
biofuels and cellulose breakdown
and now we're moving into the period
where we're using these precision
proteins for food production
and so what they've done here is
essentially taken us to where we were
a couple years ago and essentially are
modeling with
scaling and improvements in for example
new technologies like continuous flow
fermentation
they expect these to continue to drop
for yet another decade
one of the key predictions is that
they believe that industrial products
such as
whey and casing which are really chosen
and used by industrial food processors
we want the first areas to be disrupted
and they're
predicting that milk protein costs will
essentially cross over
with the weigh-in caseins costs in about
four years from now
and because there isn't uh
consumer preferences don't play a strong
role here they think that this
will transition will essentially occur
pretty much straight on price
the one that we probably know about more
in the market is essentially
fermentation
based beef you can think of impossible
burgers here where essentially people
are
taking plant proteins and adding things
like hemoglobin to them
there they think the prices are roughly
going to cross over by 2021
and then cell based beef they're
predicting that those
prices will cross over by 2025.
i think the cell based beef one is much
less clear
as to where that one's coming in on but
essentially those are their two
key predictions and
you know as i started out in our
discussion they essentially
believe that they're going to try to
eliminate
animals from the food system and
that they can cut undercut these price
points dramatically relative to
what animal production can and as you
see
even for dairy they hope to essentially
collapse the industry
so i think the question is are these
just
braggadocious claims or is there
something real to it
well the first thing i would highlight
is that essentially in the last few
years
44 alternative protein companies have
already
been started up and even in a year like
this
they're getting vast amounts of venture
capital invested
and so i want to take a look at some of
the underlying assumptions
behind this to see if this is at all
realistic
and so what i've plotted out here is
essentially the landscape of protein
prices
and on the left-hand side essentially
these are various animal proteins
um they're essentially their wholesale
prices and what i've
listed here is the cost of that item
their wholesale price and dollars per
kilogram of protein so we're assuming
that the only thing we're buying the
item for is forage protein
in the middle if you look below these
are pretty much
the high quality plant proteins that
we're used to
and then on the right hand side
essentially these are
various types of feedstocks and
fermentation
products that have high levels of
protein in them
and i'll highlight a few things here uh
that in terms of some of these costs of
you know peanuts and things like that
are in the middle here
some of you may have known i talked
about muscles a while ago and they're
right here they're actually the cheapest
animal protein that are out there
and the final thing i want you to
highlight is that the red bars are
essentially what we think x
believes these cost per proteins will be
at various time points
today is the red bar
in five years from now they believe that
precision protein will be at 10
per kilogram and then in 15 years from
now it'll be down here
so let's start with a species i know a
lot about corn
and corn's cost of protein is a little
bit above that one dollar per kilogram
because it's mostly a starch product but
today a lot of that corn goes into
production of ethanol
and that goes on to supporting
auto industry but the residual from that
is dry distillers green
those dry distillers grain are actually
the cheapest source of protein
you can buy on the planet so those are
then fed
to for example beef and there's
essentially
nearly a 65-fold difference between the
cost of that protein
and the cost of ground beef
and that's the fundamental aspect is
that price difference between those two
is where economic opportunities for
precision protein comes in
so rethink x is really predicting
disruption
of a couple key markets the first one
is that dairy market with casein and
whey
which represent about 40 of the dairy
market
and there you have nearly about
seven-fold differential and
ventral price and the other market
is for things like ground beef where
there's this 30-fold differential
between the cost of precision protein
and the cost of ground beef
is this one dollar per kilogram number
even possible
and so the first thing i would highlight
to you all is dry distillers grains
are certainly not a refined protein but
they're already well below that price
point
soybean you're not going to do it
probably directly from soybeans
they essentially cost the same as this
dollar per kilogram
soybean meal is also probably too close
in order to do it
but if you look at the cost of ammonia
and sugar
or if you were to really shift it to
ammonia and starch
and you had onsite production of ammonia
and various
aspects you can imagine that you your
feedstocks would cost about 1
8 the cost of that refined precision
protein
so i think it's certainly biochemically
possible to get to this one dollar per
kilogram
price point which could be incredibly
disruptive
to all other production systems of
protein so i think it's possible
and i think it's could happen in the
next 15 years
so if you go with rethink x's estimates
you're talking about essentially massive
impacts on land use
and economic livelihoods because
essentially half of all land has been
used for
various types of agricultural production
and the majority of that is for
livestocks
one way to think about this is that
roughly 2 billion hectares of rangeland
may no longer have a livestock market
so what would this look like for just
u.s
corn and soy land well there would
likely be a massive drop in the need for
livestock feed by mid-century processed
food may slightly go up in order to
support some of these systems
and industrial carbon would likely go up
substantially in order to
support things like plastic but still
nearly half of the acreage would not be
needed to support
current markets so this could either go
into ecosystem services which we'll talk
about more
later or the land could go compete in
things like the wheat market
but if it competed in the wheat market
this is enough land that essentially
could produce
half of the globe's total wheat meat and
would likely
displace other producers around the
globe that were less efficient
so what then would be the risk for
smallholders or rural communities
globally
well you could imagine dairy markets
pretty much disappearing
land values crashing and essentially
meat markets may be cut in half
and so those are all really big issues
for
how we support and think about these
types of transitions
that it i think could potentially come
so in the case of small holders how
could they take advantage of these types
of changes
well one way to kind of think about it
is this precision
fermentation systems really micro
brewery scale from matters
and they're maybe on the scale enough to
support
a thousand to ten thousand people
and they can produce a wide range of
different products everything from beer
to precision protein water soluble
vitamins lipid soluble vitamins
to really support most of some of the
key needs and nutrients
that people need and the inputs are
relatively simple things like major
cassava
and then ammonia either coming from the
hubble bosch reaction or from
electric arc type reactions
so how could some smallholders take
advantage of these changes
well currently most of the nitrogen that
is used for things like crop is coming
by inner cropping from legumes and other
types of biological nitrogen fixation
but if we imagine that essentially we're
shifted over to a world where maybe
we're having low protein maize
we maybe would actually recycle some of
that nitrogen and
increase nitrogen levels in the soil and
then
additionally reduce animal consumption
of stover could
both enhance carbon and soil nitrogen
and so then you're getting starch and
oil from
crops like maize and protein from
inner crop legumes and then you're
getting additional protein additional
nutritional balance from these
microbrewery type of approaches
they're being driven from the starch in
these various crops
so i think although that we're talking
about lots of instability there are some
positives that you could see for
smallholders
potentially greater food security
nutrition micro markets and co-op
fermenters
potentially better soils and higher crop
yields
due to better nitrogen balance in soils
so currently i think we're at a place
where plenty could be focused on these
things
but i think we really should be focused
in on healthy diets
a circular agriculture and sequestering
carbon
so let's first turn to healthy diets i'm
not going to go into a lot of detail
here because i think
a lot of people in our community know a
lot more about how to do this than i
but essentially i think we should really
be of
breeding for both flavor nutrient and
controlled environments
whether that's michael missouri's mini
butternut squash
mike goers work in producing high
protein
vitamin a or neil matson and colleagues
working on controlled environments i
think these are all really
key areas where we should be targeting
our breeding towards
in order to create a much wider better
set of products coming out of each of
these environments
so this is where i think new efforts
like usda's green insight can be a
really a great key partner
in helping us breed for things like
flavor nutrient and controlled
environments and i know
ars and more want to make this a high
priority and i hope we can all work
together
towards those goals the next area that
plant bridge should really focus
on is circular agriculture
and so when we talk about circular
nutrient economies what we're talking
about
is taking the amount of nitrogen
phosphorus that we certainly need for
growth of our plants to produce the food
and everything and essentially just
reducing it and keeping more of the
nitrogen on farm
and re-mobilize it through the year so
we don't need as much
nitrogen to be brought onto the farm
each year
and just a reminder in the case of maize
for example
over 80 of those greenhouse emissions
are coming from nitrogen
and then we have issues such as runoff
going into things like the gulf of
mexico
nearly 60 of the nitrogen in the gulf of
mexico is coming from agriculture
and these loss of nutrients is an
economic loss to the farmers
and it's an environmental cost
so one of the big targets we need to
focus on implant breathing
is really breeding for entire agro
ecosystems
cover crops and perennials we know if we
combine them
and the integrated breeding management
can really improve both soil biology
nutrient cycling drought and flood
tolerance
and i think a lot of these tools we're
talking about can be brought together
in order to rapidly breed for cover
crops to support
a lot of our major row crops and make
them much more
circular but i also want us to think
in other ways about how we can create a
circular
agriculture fall colors are a reminder
of how perennials are recycling nitrogen
and phosphorus the reason we're seeing
those colors is they've already moved
all their nitrogen and phosphorus out of
the leaves
and are saving that for the next year
which of these strategies can we borrow
for agriculture
we've been thinking about concepts for
example about low protein
maize where if you look at it easier
there's while it's not high in protein
because it's yield is so high there's
nearly 800 kilograms
per hectare of protein in a maize field
and if you think about that that's this
roughly the same amount of protein
that's in 14 head of steer
so what if we were able to kind of save
that back into the ground or reuse it
somehow for that coming year
could we drop the protein down where
it's not really being used very
effectively
and save it for the next year and that's
fundamentally the question
that travis rooney has been asking in
our group
he's been wondering can we make annuals
more like perennials and if you look at
the conventional major variety we take
lots of nitrogen and phosphorus
we add to our plants and we get both
volatization
and runoff of these and so we get big
losses of nitrogen phosphorus there and
then we pick up the grain
and we use a lot of the starch
and there's some uses for the protein
but for example we have too much
phosphorus in our pig lagoons and so on
and he's asked the simple question well
can we use that nitrogen phosphorus of
course during the growing season
but then leave it in the cobs and not
leave put in the kernels and essentially
then recycle those cobs
each year so that essentially we take
off the starch but we've really
focused on recycling the nitrogen and
phosphorus
for the coming year
and we've already talked about circular
agriculture and that can play an
important
role in reducing greenhouse gases and it
plays a role
in this top part of the graph where
it's either whether it's energy
production or
all sorts of other approaches we need to
really reduce
total co2 outputs fertilizer production
requires one percent of the globe's
energy the nitrous oxide coming off
our crops are major greenhouse gas and
there's greater and greater efficiency
here as a double win for both farmers
and the environment
so i'd like to now turn to what could
plant breeding do
to really sequester carbon by the end of
the century
we need to develop plants that would be
sequestering about 20 gigatons of co2
per year
there are a number of important
industrial sectors that still require
carbon compounds for decades to come
these need to be serviced first in order
to eliminate the use of fossil fuels
before we focus solely on carbon
so sequestration think there's three
main areas where plant breeding can play
a role
some of those are we're already doing
right now and that's like ethanol
production to replace gas
and you know these can be efficient
approaches
if we refine them with solar and wind
our plants can also be base polymers for
plastics
again if we solar wind energy is used to
process them
and then finally our plants and our
grasses can be used
for deep carbon uh sequestration
so i want to remind everyone that plants
are quite competitive in terms of
straight energy
on a dollar per joule basis they're much
better than wind or even natural gas
and this is where i think we need to
also look more carefully at
ethanol production and ask really why is
it not as efficient as we
would like it to be growing and
transporting
maize is really not the problem it's a
relatively minor
part of the total amount of
non-renewable energy that goes in
rather it's the ethanol conversion
especially the distillation of it
and this is where i think we should view
ethanol or like hydrogen
it's really an electron carrier and we
should use it and process
it with solar or wind energy to convert
it into a form that we can use
as a liquid fuel but it has of course
the major advantages relative to
hydrogen of already working
with the established market so
before we start sequestering carbon i
think
we need to make sure we're dealing and
have carbon neutral fuels and plastics i
would imagine
for example the transportation sector
yes it will
quickly in the next few decades maybe
convert to 75
electricity but it may still require
about a quarter of it
some kind of liquid fuel and things like
maize could essentially service it
quite well plastics again we need to
eliminate fossil fuels there
and there you could shift to essentially
100 renewable
with about 10 million hectares of maize
and as a really nice article by posing
a couple years ago highlighted you could
really go
greenhouse gas negative if you combined
it with renewable processing
and for both of these areas it's really
about the processing
that's key so now let's
turn our attention to sequestering
carbon fundamentally how do we pull
10 to 20 gigatons of co2 from air
well we do it all the time it's called
photosynthesis
and if you look at photosynthesis uh by
ecosystem
essentially across the globe it's nearly
450 gigatons per year
are being pulled out of the atmosphere
and if you divide through those
estimates from what the
national research council was estimating
to require
it's about two percent by 2050 and four
percent of that global photosynthesis
uh by 2100 and so those numbers don't
seem very big
but then you start to realize
well we really only manage a much
smaller proportion of those environments
and if you look at the ecosystems that
we manage
then you start talking about much larger
numbers you're talking about
using 5.7 and a little over 11 percent
of the photosynthetic capacity in the
sequester carbon
and now there's no way we could really
do this
if protein were competing for the exact
same land
and so this is where i think those
discussions we've had previously
on what's the nature of protein
production across the globe likely to be
over the coming decades is really
important it's essentially the same land
is needed for growth purposes
so as a reminder you know perennial
grasses out there already sequester
carbon and they grow very differently
from a lot of our annual crops
in the picture on the left what you see
is a perennial a native perennial grass
relative to annual wheat
and as you can tell they grow very
differently in terms of the root
structure
and everything else but
the question is can we shift where
they're putting some of their carbon at
the end of the year
and this is where i think there's an
opportunity for plant breeding really to
develop
deep persistent carbon and that could
happen both in our some of our annuals
and our perennials and if it's
accompanied with many of the other
optimizations we've already been talking
about
the overall harvest yield loss to above
ground part may be modest
turn to our model maze and asked the
question
what would carbon so equestrian maize
look like well
in a highly productive maze crop about
five tons of carbon is left
every year in the stover and about we
pull off about five tons
in terms of the harvested kernels
if we're willing to essentially to
create a mage plant that
say lost 10 percent of its yield and
maybe somewhat shorter we may be able to
essentially move essentially an
additional ton
of carbon every year down deeper in the
soil profile
now i do want to highlight that just as
we heard
last week from our soil science
colleagues deep carbon alone is likely
not enough carbon really needs to be
mineralized to be able to stay there
for hundreds or thousands of years and
so when we talk about that we talked
about complexing
that carbon with something like
magnesium or calcium
and getting it deep and so the questions
i think we have on the basic research
side
is how do we combine some of these
things we could do with plants
with how do we work with soil scientists
on figuring out how to mineralize it
so if we were to able to sequester
20 of the biomass to each of these areas
across the united states you start
counting up that a substantial
number of gigatons of co2
could be sequestered every year
and that totals up to about 2.9 gigatons
per year
which is about 14 of the global target
and if you think about in terms of
dollar germs a lot of people are
assuming
that carbon could be priced at nearly
50 per ton of co2 that would be
essentially an equivalent to about 142
billion dollar market by the end of the
century
for carbon sequestration so i think
there are
as you see a range of different ways we
can go about
using plant-breeding to tackle uh the
the giant problems of carbon
temperatures
but just to give it a little friend of
reference
essentially if you compare the pro size
of the problem of food production versus
carbon agriculture just
in straight amount of carbon carbon
sequestration
is about a six-fold larger problem than
feeding people
so this is a big problem and we're going
to need to use a lot of different tools
so what should plant breeding be focused
on well i think it's really about
healthy diets circular agriculture and
about
sequestering carbon but if you ask
what our biggest challenges are in the
21st century in breeding
it's really figuring out how to solve
both these goals which i think we can
really do
but we really need to be thoughtful in
planning and work with
consumers farmers and the environment
to work through these massive
transitions because none of these
transitions are going to be small
or easy
so i thank you very much and i'd be
happy to take some questions
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu